salut les épis curieuse et les épis
curieux aujourd'hui je vais vous
raconter les méfaits de trois chercheurs
sans scrupules qui ont tenté d'occuper
le public et la science préfabriqués
trucage de données expérience inventé de
toutes pièces tout de suite voici trois
des hamacs scientifiques plus folles
vous allez voir c'est à peine croyable
1 l'homme de piltdown nous sommes en
1912 piltdown un petit village situé au
sud de londres charles dawson un
paléontologue amateur décroche son
téléphone il cherche à joindre arts /
smith woodward le conservateur du
département de géologie au british
muséum dawson veut lui parler d'une
découverte qui l'a fait en se promenant
dans une carrière située près d'chez il
s'agit d'un crâne très étrange sa partie
supérieure ressemble à la nôtre mais sa
mâchoire inférieure fait furieusement
penser à celle d'un singe pour d'auxonne
sa couleur rougeâtre et usés serait
également la preuve qu'il s'agit d'un
faux cils âgés d'au moins 5 semble après
une analyse minutieuse des ossements
les deux hommes en sont convaincus ces
restes sont ceux du fameux chaînon
membres un spécimen qui serait l'ancêtre
commun du singe et de l'homme et ce
n'est pas rien les thèses de darwin sur
l'évolution des espèces ont bouleversé
les connaissances sur nos origines
depuis de nombreux scientifiques sont
persuadés que l'homme et le singe ont un
ancêtre commun qu'on ne tardera pas à
découvrir dobson et edward sont donc
persuadé de l'avoir identifié en
décembre 1912 ils présentent leurs
trésors à la société de géologie de
l'autre la communauté scientifique et
contre la nouvelle de la découverte de
ce crâne surnommé l'homme de piltdown se
répand comme une traînée de poudre dans
le monde entier on a identifié le
chaînon manquant et ce qui ne gâche rien
pendant 40 ans la majorité des
anthropologues va se satisfaire de cette
version de l'histoire toutefois certains
quand même d en avoir le coeur net des
chercheurs de l'université d'oxford
décide en 1953 de procéder à des
analyses plus poussées du crâne et le
résultat est sans appel le crâne et la
mandibule ne date pas de la même époque
et il y a pire encore l'analyse trouve
que le crâne est celui d'un homme
moderne et la mâchoire celle d'un or
entre les deux parties ont été soudés
puis vieilli à l'aide d'un traitement
chimique l'homme de piltdown est en fait
une arnaque certains pensent que charles
dawson a été victime d'une farce afin de
le discréditer une enquête est ouverte
et dont la liste des suspects un nom
bien connu circulent celui d'arthur
conan doyle l'auteur de sherlock holmes
il vivait lui même à pic d'arn
connaissait bien dansons était amateur
de canular mais aucune charge n'est
retenue contre lui et pour cause à la
clôture de l'enquète il est mort depuis
plus de 20 ans finalement en 2016 une
nouvelle étude révèle que l'auteur de
cette arnaque serait tout simplement
charles johnson lui même
élémentaire mon cher watson
2 et les souris dalmatienne aux états
unis à la fin des années 60 un jeune
dermatologue nommé william se meurt
l'hymne consacre ses recherches aux
greffes de peau il traite les grands
brûlés auxquels ils prélèvent des tissus
sains tactile grèce ensuite sur les
zones cette opération ne présente aucun
risque de rejet puisque réalisée sur un
même individu mais sommerlynck pense
qu'avec les nouveaux médicaments
immunodépresseurs qui permet d'éviter
les rejets il sera bientôt possible de
greffer la peau d'un individu sur celle
d'un homme on est bien parvenu à greffer
un pancréas en 1964 et mieux un célèbre
chirurgien sud africain a réussi la
première transplantation cardiaque en
1968 à peine un an plus tard donc le
jeune scientifique annonce à son tour
avoir réussi sonnex ils seraient
parvenus à greffer les tissus d'un homme
à la peau blanche sur un homme à la peau
noire il en tire aussitôt une certaine
notoriété
mais le doute s'immisce plusieurs
chercheurs ont tenté la même opération
sans jamais y parvenir à la faire en
reste là williams poursuit
tranquillement ses recherches à new york
sous la houlette de robert wood un
immunologiste de renommée mondiale on ne
parle plus de lui jusqu'en 1974 année où
il fait nouvelles annonces fracassantes
cette fois il prétend avoir réalisé une
greffe intéresse pèse c'est à dire entre
deux animaux non apparentés une souris
blanches et une souris noire
c'est un peu comme si l'on avait greffé
la peau d'un être humain sur un champ
pas il présente alors la preuve de son
exploit des souris blanche affublé de
jolies taches noires des souris
dalmatienne en quelque sorte mais cette
fois encore l'exploit de söderling
intrigue ses collègues si bien que ceux
ci s'empare discrètement des rongeurs et
ce qu'ils découvrent les laisse sans
voix les fameux patch de peau noire
disparaissent comme par magie à l'aide
d'un simple coton imbibé d'alcool le
petit malin avait en réalité dessiner
les tâches à l'aide d'un marqueur pas de
pot pour sommer line
cette fois il est démasqué pour se
dédouaner le dermatologue invoque la
pression qui l'aurait poussé à monter
cette supercherie en vain il est viré
sur le champ mais il ya quand même un an
de salaire sous réserve non pas de faire
un pot de départ mais de se faire
soigner aux états unis l'expression
penguins mars peindre les souris en
français est désormais devenu synonyme
de fraude scientifique
3 le cui des jumeaux au début du 20e
siècle le psychologue anglais cyril burt
est un personnage très respectée
on le considère comme pionnier de la
recherche dans le domaine de l'éducation
c'est donc à lui que l'on fait appel
pour développer des tests permettant de
déceler les difficultés d'apprentissage
chez les enfants
qu'ils aient tout va bien le hic c'est
que burt est persuadé que l'intelligence
des êtres humains est innée est
héréditaire selon lui elle n'est pas
influencée par le milieu social ou
l'apprentissage et il est bien décidé à
le prouver en procédant à des tests de
qi sur des vrais jumeaux séparés à la
naissance en 1943 les résultats tombent
et sont sans équivoque ses jumeaux qui
ont grandi dans des milieux différents
sont pourvues de capacités
intellectuelles strictement identiques
sa découverte fait grand bruit au point
d'influencer les politiques publiques en
matière d'enseignement tant en grande
bretagne aux états unis en angleterre
par exemple on décide d'utiliser les
tests de qi pour sélectionner les
étudiants pour telle ou telle filière
parfois dès l'âge de 11 ans d'autres
vont même s'appuyer sur les recherches
de burt pour valider des thèses racistes
les mauvais résultats de certains élèves
issus de minorités s'expliquerait par
une intelligence inférieure à celle des
plans inquiet par ces dérives plusieurs
chercheurs se penchent sur les études de
cyril burt après son décès en 1971 est
l'un d'entre eux léon kamin découvre que
le psychologue a trafiqué ses résultats
sur les jours il avait tout simplement
fabriquer des données de toutes pièces
pour obtenir les statistiques qu'il a
rangé sa théorie sur l'intelligence
héréditaire est donc bidon quelques
années plus tard une enquête du sunday
times révèle même que plusieurs paires
de jumeaux étudié par bird n'ont tout
simplement jamais existé depuis il a été
prouvé que l'intelligence n'est pas inné
ou héréditaires l'éducation le milieu
social et quantité d'autres facteurs
jouent un rôle très important
la science a également démontré qu'il
n'y a aucun lien entre la couleur de la
peau et l'intelligence et voilà c'est
tout pour aujourd'hui bon je vous
rassure la fraude scientifique reste un
fait très rare si vous avez aimé cette
vidéo garantie 100% sans arnaque
n'hésitez pas à liker et à vous abonner
à très bientôt les épis curieuse et les
épices curieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]